en este día solemne de recuerdo
debemos desafiarnos a nosotros mismos
a mirar atrás ya recordar
por el bien de nuestros hijos por el
bien de sus hijos
y por esa razón
también debemos mirar hacia adelante
también debemos mirar hacia el futuro
porque al final yo sí creo
que
por esa razón estaban luchando esas 40
personas por su futuro y por el nuestro
en los días
tras el 11 de septiembre de 2001 a todos
se nos recordó
que la unidad es posible en eeuu
se nos recordó también que la unidad es
un imperativo en eeuu
es esencial para nuestra prosperidad
conjuntas para la seguridad nacional
y para nuestro lugar en el mundo
y por unidad no hablo de uniformidad
hemos tenido diferencias de opiniones en
2001 así como las tenemos en 2021 y yo
creo que en eeuu nuestra diversidad es
nuestra fortaleza
a la vez
demostraste el 9/11 como el miedo puede
ser usado
para crear división en nuestra nación
a medida que los estadounidenses y
musulmanes eran hechos blancos de
ataques por su manera de orar pero
también hemos visto lo que sucede cuando
tantos estadounidenses en el espíritu de
nuestra nación
en frente están del lado del pueblo con
solidaridad con sus compañeros
estadounidenses con aquellos que
experimentan la violencia y la
discriminación
cuando estamos juntos
y mirando hacia atrás y lo podemos
recordar
la gran mayoría de estadounidenses
estaban unidos por ese propósito
ayudar a las familias a sanar ayudar a
las comunidades a recuperarse
defender a nuestra nación y mantenernos
a salvo
en un momento de terror bastante directo
nos miramos el uno al otro
frente en el rostro de un extraño vimos
a un vecino y a un amigo
ese momento nos recordó
lo significativo y la fortaleza de
nuestra unidad como estadounidenses y
nos recordó que es posible en eeuu
así que
en unos momentos
dejaremos este sitio sagrado
aún cargando con nosotros el dolor
de esta pérdida esta tremenda pérdida
y así
el futuro seguirá desarrollándose
enfrentaremos nuevos desafíos
desafíos que no hubiéramos podido ver
hace 20 años
tomaremos las oportunidades que se nos
presenten
que en algún momento fueron
inimaginables y ahora sabemos que lo que
viene
no guarda certezas nunca ha guardado
certezas pero si sea algo
si hacemos el trabajo duro
de unirnos como estadounidenses
si permanecemos unidos por nuestro
propósito
estaremos preparados para lo que sea que
venga después
los 40 pasajeros y los miembros de la
tripulación el vuelo 93 como ya todos
sabemos a ellos no se conocían muchos de
ellos no sabían quiénes eran eran
personas diferentes de diferentes
lugares
estaban en ese vuelo particular por
distintas razones
pero ellos no se enfocaron en lo que
podría separarlos no
ellos se centraron en lo que todos
compartíamos en la humanidad de la
humanidad que todos compartimos
en unos cuantos minutos
en una de las circunstancias más
peligrosas
esas 40 personas respondieron como una
sola lucharon por sus propias vidas y
por salvar las vidas de
incontables vidas en la capital de
nuestra nación después de hoy esperó y
oró por que podamos continuar honrando
su coraje
sus convicciones
con las nuestras que podamos honrar su
unidad al fortalecer nuestros lazos en
común al fortalecer nuestra él ya
nuestras alianzas globales y siempre
viviendo y reconociendo nuestros mayores
ideales ese trabajo no será fácil y
nunca lo ha sido y tomara
ahora requerirá que todos nosotros
creamos en quiénes somos como una nación
y regenerar que todos nosotros
empezamos a trabajar juntos muchas
gracias a todos que dios los bendiga y
que dios bendiga a estados unidos muchas
gracias